[Música]
alguém se lembra da fabiana de jesus uma
mulher morena cabelo cacheado assim um
pouco abaixo do ombro não sabe onde
jesus foi vítima de algo precisamos
combater com urgência notícia falsa em
2014 um sábado qualquer de sol no
guarujá os vizinhos da fabiana entraram
na casa dela e arrastaram ela pra rua
pontapé chute na costela chute nas
costas e por que porque uma página de
facebook tinha postado retrato falado
que vocês estão vendo e os vizinhos
tinham achado que aquela mulher no
retrato falado era fabiano
a mulher do retrato falado até parece
com ela era acusada de supostamente
seqüestrar crianças na região do guarujá
e praticar magia negra
a fabiana em nada tinha a ver com a
história
naquele dia a fabiana deixou dois filhos
teve traumatismo craniano e morreu
vítima de notícia falsa
recentemente há duas semanas apenas um
casal como eu e meu marido vocês e suas
esposas e maridos estavam em araruama na
região dos lagos no rio de janeiro
dirigir um carro branco e de repente uma
multidão avassaladora circulou o carro
fizeram com que eles parassem
pegaram pedras paus atacaram o carro
como vocês podem ver essas imagens e
porquê porque na região circulava no
workshop a informação de que um casal em
um carro branco se cogitava crianças
também o casal em nada tinha a ver com a
história quase morreu
vocês podem dizer a essa coisa de brasil
não em 14 de julho do ano passado quando
a frança celebrar o seu feriado nacional
um caminhão atropelou e matou mais de 80
pessoas em nice uma cidade muito
tranquila e linda
um professor que estava no canadá e não
tinha absolutamente nada a ver com
aquela história sequer havia pisado
início foi acusado de ser um homem por
trás daquele atentado terrorista e por
quê porque ele havia postado uma foto um
self na internet
na primeira imagem vocês vêem um homem o
professor canadense com o seu turbante
sic que a religião que professa na
frente de um espelho carregando um ipad
apenas a foto foi roubada na internet
adulterada em photoshop e na segunda
imagem vocês vão continuam vendo o
turbante siquila mas o ipad virou um
corão e ele ganhou que de adorno na
roupa um colete de bombas durante dias o
professor canadense sofreu o ódio
virtual foi ameaçado de bomba de morte
foi ameaçado não só ele à família dele
por pouco muito muito pouco o professor
canadense não virou fabiano de jesus e
por pouco muito pouco eu e vocês não
viram os camiões de jesus todos os dias
a mentira tem perna curta e não a
mentira tem pernas longas e olhar vocês
agora para a infância
a gente brincava de telefone sem fio
todo mundo lembra assim eu contava uma
frase para o meu amigo contava com outro
amigo que no final disse uma besteira
que não tinha nada a ver com a frase
original e todo mundo ria porque na
internet ninguém mais volta a fonte
original para rir porque a gente trata a
informação final como a verdadeira
sabendo que o copiar e colar na internet
gera transtorno gera mudança na
informação
ter diversa tudo propõe também uma
revisão da teoria da comunicação pra
gente comunicar uma informação precisa
de alguns ingredientes o emissor o
receptor
o código a mensagem o contexto onde essa
informação está circulando e o canal
agora vamos parar pra pensar um
minutinho o que aconteceu com o canal
nos últimas décadas encurtou hoje em dia
aquele espaço que antes era ocupado por
pessoas como eu jornalistas
profissionais que escutava informação
num canto burlavam filtravam e
entregavam pra os receptores uma
informação de melhor qualidade
desapareceu esse espaço por exemplo a ex
presidente dilma rousseff
ela tem cinco milhões de seguidores no
twitter
ela está 140 caracteres de se comunicar
com cinco milhões de pessoas sem que
absolutamente ninguém possa interferir
nessa mensagem é a mesma coisa acontece
no extremo oposto a gente pode pegar por
exemplo deputado federal jair bolsonaro
tem 300 mil seguidores no twitter a
última vez que eu conferi ele também
pode falar o que ele quiser
num canal cada vez mais curto onde há
cada vez menos interferência e filtro
existe uma empresa que fez um estudo uma
empresa americana chamadas ou chiflón
fez um estudo sobre essa proliferação de
tweets e alcance desses twitts elevou
esse estudo
depois foi batizado de lei do twitter
falso para apresentar em harvard nos
estados unidos
no primeiro tweet que a empresa analisou
é no twitter da nbc informava que a
cidade de nova york tinha uma
manifestação
imaginem uma nova york pós 11 de
setembro ea informação chega acompanhado
de uma segunda informação é a de que o
espaço aéreo sobre aquela região está
fechado muito bem
acontece que essa informação estava
errada que aconteceu houve um segundo
tweet
corrigindo esse dado corrigindo assim
havia manifestação mas o espaço ainda
não estava fechado
esse segundo item foi publicada
aproximadamente 20 minutos depois do
primeiro eu vou mostrar pra vocês agora
no telão o sucesso de audiência
o tuíte falso em verde
o tuíte azul com a correção isso leva à
conclusão da lei do twitter falso e eu
queria parar e pedir que vocês todos
analisassem o que comportamento que
vocês têm todos os dias nas redes
sociais
compartilhamos aquilo em que acreditamos
compartilhamos aquilo que gostamos e
queremos que seja verdade algum dia não
necessariamente aquilo que já é verdade
segundo correções não fazem sucesso não
são populares correções
o gráfico acho que ficou claro mostrou
isso e assim chega nesse nessa expressão
que talvez alguns conheçam talvez outros
não mas eu faço manhã fazer após verdade
a expressão que entrou no dicionário
oxford do ano passado pra dizer e
resumir como foi 2016 no mundo inteiro e
pós verdade meus amigos é esse cenário
em que a gente vive onde não importa o
que é real
não importa o fato importa aquilo que eu
acredito aquilo que eu quero que seja
verdade aquilo que eu gosto e aquilo que
é igual a mim
nós estamos nos afastando do que é
verdadeiro estamos nos aproximando do
que a crença de moderno não tem nada
também no ano passado o mundo assistiu à
eleição do dom e por que eu trago hoje o
dono de chan foi um dos homens mais
checados e acompanhados da história da
imprensa mundial eu acho que eu posso
falar isso com certa tranqüilidade
o site americano the huffington post um
pouco preocupado com a quantidade de
informações trocadas em que o
republicano estava dando durante a
campanha resolveu escalar uma equipe de
cinco jornalistas profissionais para
acompanhar o que o trombo falava durante
uma hora em 60 minutos meus amigos
acreditem 71 informações equivocadas
desde falsos absurdos
até pequenos deslizes que qualquer um de
nós identificaremos apesar de não sermos
americanos e que aconteceu nada
o som foi eleito na platéia certamente
tem gente dizendo a culpa do mark
zuckeberg sempre eu concordo em parte é
verdade o facebook tem um algoritmo e o
algoritmo decide o que a gente recebe
nova timeline nos nossos feeds de
notícias
também concordo que recentemente o
facebook fez mano anúncio internacional
público de que esse algoritmo está
desenhado para aproximar pessoas que já
se conhecem ou seja os nossos amigos dos
nossos familiares e até acho que isso
faz sentido eu prefiro saber o que meu
marido postou na internet antes do que o
seu
mas que isso gera bolhas bolhas digitais
bolhas onde só convivemos com aqueles
que são nossos amigos nossos conhecidos
e aí vamos fazer um exercício rapidinho
com a propriedade de alguém de extrema
direita fica amigão de alguém de extrema
esquerda
qual é a probabilidade de alguém da
lambaeróbica curtir a galera da ioga e
qual é a chance real de alguém que gosta
de heavy metal andar com a galera do axé
e assim estamos nós todos dentro das
nossas bolhas e aí vem a nossa parte de
culpa em toda essa história
quebra a bolha transforma em suas redes
sociais em lugares incómodos em lugares
que desafiou sua cabeça
vamos treinar nossos olhos para aquilo
que é diferente daquilo que está em
desacordo com o que acreditamos porque
porque faz bem porque nos tira da bolha
talvez vocês não saibam mas a notícia
falsa é feita não só pelo prazer de
divulgá-lo de ser falso dar dinheiro
muito dinheiro algum sábado do jornal
folha de são paulo fez uma longa
reportagem
localizou em poços de caldas em minas
gerais
um grupo de jovens como vocês na platéia
que aprender a usar o adsense que é um
sistema de distribuição de bananas do
google e juntaram e sabedoria é a
capacidade de construir páginas na
internet e gerar notícias e posts em
redes sociais com títulos para lá de
chocantes um pouco ver a cidade e que
acontece você clica eu clico nós
aplicamos e eles enchem os bolsos à
folha de são paulo calculou que esse
grupo de poços de caldas chegou a mover
150 mil reais em um único mês
só para vocês terem uma idéia do que
estou falando
alguém já ouviu falar deles velhos fica
na macedônia e porque eu tava macedônia
por ted shifu brincar na rua porque foi
de vélez que saíram as páginas de fake
news que povoaram as eleições americanas
do ano passado
há dezenas de reportagens na imprensa
americana
revelando que grupos semelhantes ao de
poços de caldas atuaram na macedônia
para influenciar a eleição americana que
não está por todos os lados pode afetar
qualquer um a qualquer hora e onde isso
vai parar gente na minha opinião um
humilde opinião não vai parar
esse estudo do instituto rogers que é um
instituto que monitora o consumo de
informação do mundo perguntou em 2013
para jovens que vivem nos centros
urbanos do mundo como eles consomem
notícia onde eles se informam e 47 por
cento destes jovens disseram redes
sociais ea mesma pergunta foi feita o
ano passado ea resposta redes sociais
para 72 por cento dos jovens
não há nenhum indício de que o consumo
de notícias na internet em redes sociais
pará e também não há nenhum indício de
que a notícia falsa vai parar
então eu trago para vocês aqui algumas
técnicas
muito simples eu sou factcheck checador
de dados de fatos e discursos
eu faço parte da internet não fec
network que a associação internacional
de jogadores de dados
e essas dicas que eu vou trazer para
vocês agora são relativamente simples de
serem postas em prática e eu posso
garantir se elas realmente foram postas
em prática por vocês
a gente faz a diferença a partir de hoje
sairemos da nossa inércia
a primeira dica é um dado sem fonte de
nada serve de onde vem esse número se
você não souber se por responder essa
informação simplesmente ignora se dado
por favor
2 cuidado com o número relativo gente
porcentagem é um risco afinal de contas
uma coisa pode ter sim subido 100 por
cento mas tento de 1 para 2 e continuar
relevante vamos combinar dados em
mutação cuidado quando as pessoas e
sobretudo os políticos fizeram
comparações de informações como saúde e
violência que são dados que infelizmente
mudam a cada instante e que também
infelizmente são computados com
metodologia diferente de um estado para
o outro também duvidem especialmente
reforços políticos que me odeiam quando
algum deles disseque a causa b
qual é a coisa qual fator na nossa vida
que é tão simples assim
duvido dessas informações dessas
relações causais simples chegou sem b se
eu perco a paciência com isso e por fim
por favor não tolera em frases que
contém a expressão a maior do mundo a
menor do mundo a pior o menor do mundo
qual é a chance real daquele fulano ter
checado mundo inteiro 0 no mínimo está
exagerando
desde 2004 eu trabalho com o facto de a
cni isso trazendo pra vocês hoje já
acontece no brasil em 2014 quando eu
ainda era sua editora de política do
jornal o globo no rio de janeiro
nós implantamos o primeiro blog do jec
do país
naquela eleição de 2014 nós trabalhamos
por 90 dias e analisam os 374 frases
ditas por todos os candidatos à
presidência da época e pelos dois
principais colocados nas pesquisas de
intenção de voto de seis estados das 374
frases que a gente avaliou 48 por cento
tinham algum grau de desinformação
agora por favor imagine o que teria sido
a campanha eleitoral e o resultado
obviamente se nós todos eleitores não
tivéssemos sido alvo de tanta besteira
hoje eu dirijo à agência lusa é a
primeira agência de notícias do brasil a
se dedicar plenamente ao fat shopping eu
seleciono frases ditas por aí
contraste essas frases com bancos de
dados públicos e cravo se elas são
verdadeiras ou falsas
faço isso porque eu vivo em dúvida
constante e essa posição ela é agradável
eu duvido até do meu marido que me diz
vamos lá fora vai todo mundo eu todo
mundo ou não cabe mas como já vi eu
cheguei no site aqui né
no dia em que eu participei de um evento
na colômbia medellín na colômbia e que
estava lá o cheque ado que é uma
referência norte americana chantagem e
assistir um vídeo estava na platéia como
vocês assistir um vídeo em espanhol em
que a diretora do chiado perguntava
assim mostrando um monte de imagens
semelhantes às que estão vendo porque é
mesmo que todos nós nos reunimos para
ver a copa do mundo para ir a jogo o
tipo de futebol para assistir a um show
de rock pra rezar e até pra ver no
domingo assiste um tédio porque a gente
faz isso a gente não se une para
procurar a verdade porque a gente se une
para fazer tudo isso e não luta contra a
mentira a informação de qualidade é
poder gente quem tem informação tem
poder
se você está bem informado você consegue
decidir desde coisas simples como em que
colégio ou matricular meu filho
até coisas muito sérias como quem é ver
quem é que vai me representar em
brasília
sem informações de qualidade vocês são
incapazes de tomar essas decisões e
conscientemente
vocês estão sendo manipulados pela
desinformação e é por isso que a gente
ouve hoje dizer o seguinte vamos montar
um exército de checadores somos todos
capazes de fazer tudo isso juntos e será
um enorme um enorme prazer chegar junto
com vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]